c'est vraiment une détente
nos maris d'ailleurs un pêcheur mais
là-bas et moi même mon fils m'a permis
de pouvoir fête des mères à l'image de
ce qu'a fait hier et ce matin j'ai fait
deux trois petites perches empêchaient
tout ça ment pas mes supérieurs
voilà à l'image d'anne marie ils étaient
des milliers aujourd'hui à taquiner le
poisson ruisseau et plans d'eau étaient
pris d'assaut que l'on soit
professionnel ou amateur l'heure était
au plaisir tout simplement ça détend la
pêche rien à faire que vous preniez du
poisson qu'on en prenait aucune
importance c'est le fait de le croire de
croire que vous allez prendre quelque
chose quoi
si vous prenez tant mieux si vous prenez
pas tant pour objectif des organisateurs
séduire les enfants et tous ceux qui
n'ont jamais tenues de cannes à pêche
entre leurs mains objectifs a priori
réussi pour m'amuser pour prendre du
poisson ce qui est intéressant dans la
pêche et prendre du poisson qu'on
attrape le plus qu'aujourd'hui en
islande au plus celui qui prend plus de
poissons ils gagnent
il a des cadeaux une fois jean m jean mi
chez les filles si tweets étaient un
secret pour attraper les poissons non
oui voilà noblat et voilà la boucle du
poisson alors si vous aussi vous voulez
affronter truites carpes brochets
laissez vous aller vous avez jusqu'à
demain soir pour le faire en toute
liberté